dog here manager Michelle Desmond
supervises the arrival of a dog they
first encountered two years ago vivy a
mixed breed has come to dog town because
she displays aggressive behavior dog
town first worked with Vivian in the
fall of 2005 when they rescued her from
the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina
thousands of people were forced to
evacuate New Orleans without their pets
best friends mobilize teams to save many
of the stranded animals those found were
often starving barely surviving with
little food water or shelter for weeks
best friends rescued probably close to
4,000 animals during Hurricane Katrina
many of which were reunited with their
homes there we go and then others went
to other groups
unable to locate Vivian's family best
friends placed her in an animal shelter
in New York where she appeared to show
symptoms similar to post-traumatic
stress Hurricane Katrina was really
scary for a lot of dogs it was very
traumatic and something that traumatic
can have long lasting effects and you
know now we have to kind of pick up the
pieces from from what we see them going
through now Vivian Spears cause her to
turn against strangers and sometimes the
very people who are trying to help her
at the shelter
Vivian constantly growled and lunged at
her caregivers making her dangerous to
handle the group she was with had told
us that you know she was pretty
threatening through the family and that
she had cornered one caregiver in the
run
and then he went to pet her on a lead
and she did kind of lunge and snap at
him Michelle needs to teach Vivian to
overcome her fears and learn to trust
people in order to have a second chance
at life in an adoptive home